well congratulations i mean
you
you're like i've been reading you're the
uh one to watch here on oh gosh
is that pressure that's pressure that's
pressure
everyone is so good this season yeah to
be
at a
three-way tie for the top tonight it was
just so awesome yeah especially because
jojo and jenna did such an amazing job
olivia
shocked us all blown away by olivia um i
you know everybody just everyone yeah
coming in to the ballroom each week
bringing it you know we're all working
so hard everyone everyone you can tell
that everyone wants to be here they're
leaving their hearts on the floor and it
looks amazing and it's so nice to be
part of such a beautiful show
and amanda you had i mean you've already
done one live show today with a big
announcement so
tell me about natalie joining your the
talk
i mean it was a huge announcement we
were able to say this morning oh my gosh
we're so excited to have natalie i mean
you know talk about a woman that has
been in this business um you know
shining such a bright light her smile
warms you know america's hearts i think
that you know her joining our team is
just going to
make us even better i can't wait to have
her on board i can't wait to be her
co-worker and i i think it's like the
best news that could have ever happened
for us
and
getting back to the ballroom uh i want
to know uh brittany as an inspiration
what do you think she's what would you
want to say to her right now after you
know dancing
brittany it was an honor to dance to
circus tonight as
a you know woman as a mom as somebody
who feels like her life is a circus a
lot of times but then
like loves to perform and feels like she
understands what a circus is
i just bow down to you i think it was an
honor to be able to dance to your music
tonight and you guys kicked it off i
mean was that
that was so much fun the ballroom was
electric and
it felt so nice to just go out there and
have fun yeah i really did
now i gotta ask
do you this much in this far in are you
guys any disagreements any
i wouldn't say disagreements i feel like
we communicate really well with each
other so
if it is a hard day
we try to work it out and and amanda is
one of the hardest workers so i'm very
lucky that i can push her and she can
push back
yeah no we do we communicate really well
we don't let anything fester or harbor
over to the next day like we just deal
with it and go on and then come back the
next day like ready to work you know i
mean it's such a limited time that you
have in these rehearsal rooms so there's
in my opinion there's like no time to
let things fester it's just like let's
get it on the table let's work hard next
day let's go most of the time it's fun
though
amanda i just got to say like i already
mentioned that you do a live show every
day
and you're doing this how are you
managing all of that i mean you must be
joining
a mom
and
i run hooray for and my fitness company
and my app
yeah i said to alan uh when i got here i
feel like i sometimes have 10
personalities that i have to like put on
like just different hats that i wear i'm
really good at car park analyzing my
life i'll say that i can like you know
do that something and then like move to
the next thing and do that thing and
then move to the next thing i think it's
the only way i can survive
you